President Trump appears to be ready to
make a big White House staff shake-up
sources tell CBS News chief of staff
John Kelly could be on his way out in a
matter of days his expected exit comes
amid big staff announcements president
Trump travels to Philadelphia later
today for the Army versus Navy football
game Nikole Killion joins us from the
White House Nicole good morning good
morning to you Adriana and president
Trump's relationship with chief of staff
John Kelly has been strained for some
time the two are reportedly no longer on
speaking terms and Kelly's authority in
the White House has dwindled to
virtually nothing
president Trump Friday ignored questions
about the future of his chief of staff's
job people leave White House sources
tell CBS News chief of staff John
Kelly's exit is imminent
the last thing I wanted to do is walk
away from one of the great honors of my
life being the Secretary of Homeland
Security but I did something wrong and
God punished me I guess vice president
Pence's chief of staff Nick Ayers is
seen as the leading contender to replace
Kelly meanwhile President Trump Friday
announced he is nominating William Barr
as his new Attorney General he was my
first choice from day one respected by
Republicans and respected by Democrats
if confirmed Barr would return to the
position he first held under President
HW Bush some Democrats called on Barr to
allow special counsel Robert Muller's
investigation to proceed unimpeded after
Barnes passed criticism of the Russia
probe Heather now nominated mr. Trump
filled another vacancy naming the State
Department spokesperson and former Fox
News anchor to replace nikki Haley at
the UN she's very talented very smart
very quick and I think she's going to be
respected by all prompting some
Democratic lawmakers to criticize her
lack of foreign policy experience he is
a challenging individual amid the latest
White House staff shake-up former
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson had
critical words for his old boss when the
president would say well here's what I
want to do and here's how I want to do
it
and I'd have to say to him well mr.
president I understand what you want to
do but you can't do it that way it
violates the law it violates the treaty
you know it and and he you know he just
he got really frustrated President Trump
lashed back tweeting Tillerson was dumb
as Iraq and lazy as hell we are
expecting another big announcement today
President Trump teased that he'll be
making it at that army vs. Navy game
this afternoon at Lincoln Financial
Field in Philadelphia Dana
Nikole Killion at the White House Nicole
thank you